so Cohen's off to the clink how did the
media respond to which I say so what I
mean we all knew this guy was Shady he's
so shady you could hold a picnic under
him but that's really not on Trump it's
not against the law to have a dirty
lawyer nor is it to have a dirty lawyer
who pays off women you slept with in
fact I believe if you're a real estate
contractor from Queens it's in the human
resources handbook as mandatory behavior
step 1 sleep with a porn star step 2
hire a fixer to pay her off step 3 find
another porn star this is why I'm not
running for president you know what I've
noticed every president has questionable
friends who do things for them who then
get into hot water once you're elected
the last thing I want to do is get my
slimy dirt ball friends in trouble I
have so many which is why I'm announcing
today that I will not be running in 2020
which means more time for travel maybe
to see old friends I wonder how my
college roommates will react
[Applause]
I'll see you soon little buddies fact is
payoffs are unseemly but they're not
illegal even more Trump uses own money
unlike the creeps in Congress who tapped
our pockets for sexual harassment
payoffs which may be why Nancy Pelosi
now agrees with me telling the media to
shut the F up I wish that the press
would spend a lot more time on what we
need to do here to meet the needs of
American people instead of morning noon
and night allegations against the
president I think you'd have more
viewers or readers that think that would
address concerns that people have rather
than just this ongoing ongoing coverage
of what what's current with the
president from one day to the next well
slap my face with a tapeworm someone's
been watching this show cuz I couldn't
have said it better myself I probably
could have but anyway but if Nancy gets
it then she must know this collusion
crap is going nowhere
yeah collusion remember when that was
the big story now it's vanished like a
pot brownie at Gary Johnson's house
nobody remembers Gary he eats a lot of
pot brownies yet the media still keep
saying what about Russia 57 different
ways they're like a talking bottle of
ketchup anyway too bad about that
meeting earlier this week we need border
security the wall is a part of border
security you can't have very good border
security without the wall now is a way
to effectively respond the experts say
you can do border security without a
wall which is wasteful and doesn't solve
the problem
it totally solves the problem
now the media went nuts but I loved it
of course every time Trump acts like
Trump the media's hair catches fire
which which I think might be a threat to
public safety here you have a normal
conversation between adults and the
media gets in a tither
which i think is German for leather
bodysuit I think that she was saying no
bands leaning here let me remind you who
I am what do you make of Trump's posture
sitting in that room the way he says the
hole he always what do you call that
it's like I don't know he's a man spread
or wherever you're caught look at that
look he widens his legs as far as
possible Nance man spread spreading or
whatever mansplaining Chris has not not
lost it amazing it's like none of these
people know people who call them out on
stuff could that be it are they all
living in their parents basements
talking to their cockatoo but Nancy
Chuck badly wanted the wall discussion
done privately while Trump's like now
let's do it here he had nothing to hide
but they did it was almost as if he knew
he was right and poor Chuck everyday
morphing into the penguin from Batman
[Laughter]
so true meanwhile meanwhile hell these
guys are working on their act for Vegas
the president went toe-to-toe with his
new foe and he got man chucked his new
foe the man Chuck I like because it
sounds like you know the martial arts do
I get an amen on my new nickname of Nan
Chuck
Don Lemon gave it to me I was gonna go
with polymer that's terrible with
polymer or shmall Oh see I had polymer
and shallow sea you were like a nan
Chuck went over well you were right
about that
ah they really are the Lenny and Squiggy
of cable news without that without the
Lenny they're both really Squiggy now I
get it Trump made them that way but
overlooking all of this this guy
yep Mike Pence as stoic as an Easter
Island attraction
Undertaker's tell him to loosen up he
kind of reminds me of me when I watched
Sarah Silverman tell a joke
but really he's just doing his part to
represent Trump's grandest promise a
wall he became at that moment a wall and
Trump was saying if we don't have a wall
I'm just gonna send a thousand Pence's
to the border they will all walk arms
and remain motionless oh you know what
looking at pants I do wonder what the
hell was he thinking God the Greg
Gutfeld show is so funny
I know what that guy's like I bet he's
awesome bet he'd be fun to go fishing
with buy a boat but I don't live near
water does that matter
well Greg think I'm weird if I have a
boat and I don't live near water
probably making fun of me I can't excuse
me but I can't get it passed in the
house it's not gonna mean if I get the
boat first I can move closer the water
should I move closer the water then get
the boat then the boat salesman will see
me a mile away whoa look at this guy he
just moved near water he's probably
gonna buy a boat this is a bad idea
if Greg only likes me because I have a
boat then I don't need his friendship
it's really not my friend after all
Craig's a big stupid jerk and I hate his
big stupid face
Wow that's good
while most of us saw this is another
week others still get so dramatic
some said things you could lose your job
over or worth that I could lose my job
over is that a patriot speaking or a
wannabe dictators but voice she called
the Secretary of State an anti-gay slur
of course he apologized faster than you
could say join Reid but it sucked on
Twitter so she apologized again the term
is crass and offensive and I apologize
to everyone especially the LGBTQ
community and to my colleagues for using
it it was a mistake my father would have
found it so unbecoming and disrespectful
and he would have told me I will work
hard to be better now we should accept
the apology people like mica who don't
accept apologies or jerks but boy I can
safely say if it were me who said it I
doubt she'd say forgive and forget I'd
have more pitchforks in me than the farm
supply aisle at Home Depot
but the incident kind of tells you
something because the daughter of a
diplomat like she said she's a symbol of
elitism and the establishment cocktail
circuit and the word that comes to her
mind about a Secretary of State is that
word meaning she'll be fine she's
protected for two years Trump has been
accused of saying awful things but
nothing quite like that
warning Joe truly has become a race to
the bottom
[Applause]
woke up tonight yes he puts the fine and
Finance stock market guru and financial
analyst Heather he's so funny strangers
slap his knee writer and comedian Chris
freed she's bold likes to scold and
complains about the cold National Review
reporter Kat temps Niagara Falls is his
drinking fountain former WWE Superstar
my massive sidekick and host of own PC
on Fox Nation Cyrus alright Heather what
was your take on that whole wall meeting
done in public I loved it I couldn't
stop watching one part that wasn't shown
is is Pelosi said we're gonna call this
a trump shutdown and under his breath he
said well I was gonna call it a Pelosi
shutdown but everyone was happy as soon
as Chuck Shumer Chuckie Schumer said
will you please acknowledge that this
time you take credit for the shutdown
because he had to take credit for it in
August they called her Schumer shut down
and he said you know what Chuck I'll
take credit for it so this time as long
as he takes credit for Chuck and Nancy
are happy they're off the hook that's
all they cared about yeah that's true
and by the way and that's always Trump's
kind of motto is that he'll take the
heat he doesn't mind I mean he can't get
much worse the heat is already hot Chris
much unlike you thanks for dressing down
welcome we helping your friends move
before you got here no later
are those sweatpants they are not there
my first ever black jeans in life and
well you know what bloodhounds are
sweats night sweats Chris next time I'm
gonna wear actual tights but yes I hope
you do maybe that's my goal is to get
you into tight yeah I've heard that yes
Chris monk of the week how's my mica
impression yeah yeah that was very good
a very good mica president when did you
make of the week you can pick what sweet
that meeting I really enjoyed so he
Trump Bates people in yes everyone acts
like the you know shutting down the
government it sounds bad he's ruining
America he knows people are gonna freak
out and then it's gonna work itself I
think he treats he talks to them like a
family going to Disney and he's like
I'll turn this car around and they go no
no you can't no yeah and he's like I'll
do it I'm gonna shut it down it will
work out yeah in fact I don't mind the
government shutting down cat I don't I
think you would agree with me I do agree
with you Greg okay next question I don't
I do it on my pants and also I don't
think that anybody who supports Trump is
going to care even if it is his shut
down and he says it's his shut down
because it's for border security and
that's one of the things he ran on that
was so important to a lot of the people
and the reason why a lot of people voted
for him so they're probably happy to see
a Republican actually standing up for
things rather than just caving like a
lot of the Republicans have in the past
laughs word I think the biggest thing
was first of all I'd like to give Nancy
Pelosi some kudos here because this is
why the media didn't want her back right
you're right this is why because she
came to work she came to work with a
president United States and that's why
they were making fictitious people to
run against her like she doesn't have
the votes right cuz uh our MacDonald's
gonna run against her for next but they
were trying to create havoc because
she's literally like let's work yeah
with the president so kudos her for that
and this is very simple with the wall
it's a campaign promise which is a huge
reelection chip right so he's on the
things he's done well tax reform foreign
policy and stuff like that those are
things in his bag that when he real
extra stars because I've done this I've
done this health care is not yeah so but
if he has a visual please turn your to
the screen and look at the beautiful
wall we built right it's a little hard
to run against that yeah cuz I'm pretty
sure it right into it
so if they say no no no and if lightning
strikes in the they win I guarantee you
the first thing they'll do is be like
we're gonna put in a wall yeah but
they'll call it a standing apparatus to
deter migrant workers from getting over
like it's gonna be it's gonna be a
different name but the wall Hillary was
for the wall everyone's for the wall is
just because it's it'll go it'll go
credit to him and we'll really kind of
lock in his reelection yeah you know
what I think that Trump has it backwards
he keeps saying we're gonna build the
wall and have Mexico pay for it
my theory is Mexico builds the wall and
we pay Mexico because what does Mexico
need jobs right build it on the side of
Mexico you have no more eminent domain
problems and we're out sorting out
thank you unfortunately I am not running
for president
because I have too many strange friends